what I think this shows is the continual
weakness of the Prime Minister because
there's a double weakness here he should
never have appointed him in the first
place along with other members of the
cabinet that shouldn't have been
appointed and then he didn't sack him
and even today it's Rob who resigned
rather the Prime Minister who acts and I
think you know we're here at
Middlesbrough College I've been talking
to the next generation of NHS staff they
desperately want to talk about the
future of the NHS and here we are
talking about these weaknesses at the
top of the Tory party and I think you
know in the end after 13 years it just
demonstrates that no matter how many
times you change the person at the top
you've essentially got a party that just
can't deliver just can't govern Dominy
Robb said depending on the findings of
the report he would resign he has now
resigned he's done the right thing
hasn't he well the big question for the
prime minister is why he was so weak to
appoint him in the first place the
second question for the prime minister
is why he didn't sack him and now it's
left to Dominic Robb to resign and the
Prime Minister hasn't acted and it's
that indecision it's that weakness I
think that goes to the heart not just of
this prime minister but of 13 years now
of failure and it's why people
desperately want to change and also you
know there's a bigger picture here we've
got a cost of living crisis there's a
future of the NHS that
um you know is really really important
I've been talking to students here who
are the future Workforce of the NHS they
desperately want to talk about the NHS
and we're mired in talking about the
weaknesses and the inability of the
government to actually deliver anything
for the people of this country Mr Rob
has resigned he's gone down fighting
those taken aim at the inquiry saying
that uh in setting a threshold for
bullying so low it set a dangerous
precedent it'll encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of government and ultimately
the British people I don't know why
Dominic craft thinks Dominic Robb in the
middle of a cost of living crisis
thinks that anybody wants to hear about
his whining about having to resign what
I think everybody wants is strong
leadership and that has been palpably
absent here